oh my god Tacoma I think it's it's shot
oh look at all the blood it's all sticky
and gooey wait a minute is that an Irish
tradition yeah try it it's sweet
delicious
you are one tasty black man I think in
Betty syrup
he smells like Swedish pancakes they
pelted me with it said it was a warning
that was sweet feta making bastards what
are we gonna do I'll cook us up some
Irish bacon the least we can do is make
him part of a complete breakfast alright
so I don't know what this one is it
doesn't have a label could I don't know
if that's a good thing or a bad thing
[Music]
[Applause]
I've not I've actually never taken the
fun to that level I've never done
screaming out in the hallway I got that
out of my system in college by the way
the whether or not this is gonna be good
or bad the no label you have fun with it
kind of tastes like jellybeans vaginas
to jellybean vaginas there are some
people who study and micromanage games
of Pokemon like that when they're
running around randomly they take all
the fun out of it when they just make it
to to complicate it pokemons a game
dorks this is cool stuff right here I'm
having a good time I'm having a great
time worrying about stuff that I will
never look up later they work it's a
bomb advert and that's the thing that
you want to you want to bring up to your
dentist isn't it well I was the terrible
Tim Allen impression yeah it is word of
mouth it is community it is meeting
someone else you send that word of mouth
by way by chance that'd be great
I could get more people to look at demo
real that'd be wonderful if you make
them laugh after work they come back to
you all the time
I think they laugh but not for the right
reasons I don't know I mean it's like
III try to point out some of the flaws
that these movies have you know that
that's see to me that's showing how
we're like sort of above them and like
how we can do Americans we're seeing the
problems and we're acknowledging it and
that's what's so great
don't let the bird get in the way of my
excellent thought there I I think it's a
very good thought it was it was a good
bubble it's it's expanding you've been
bashing almost everything out which is
fine a lot of people a lot of people do
that I do that non-stop but also that
something I like
what do you come back to that you that
you enjoy at least isn't is there is
this enjoyment or you just Sisyphus walk
in the rock up the hill again and again
you see a movie called um blue patches
I've never heard of blue patches a lot
of people haven't it's it's my favorite
movie if you you were gonna pitch it to
me as someone who cared about it Wow how
how can I care about it um the acting is
really good I don't know there's just
something about that about the way that
they do it that's just um you just see
something you just say that's that's
perfect and you can't explain why it
just is you know if you want to learn
more about check it out
I'm sure you can find it I got you here
right now
no no really not it there's nothing I
can say about it that it doesn't say for
itself now let's just leave it at that
I'm gonna have some more of this
I liked this are you sure that is wise
no but I'm gonna do it I can handle it
I'm fine yeah it doesn't sound like a
good idea Tony oh right now I'm fine mr.
Hollywood
it's
it's you can see really don't think you
should have any more of that well I'm
fine sir what is what is the worst that
can happen
that was beautiful delicious sound you
can't even look at him
they were masks what were you doing out
there I thought they were after you did
you know a same thing where today hello
response time is that your car being
told and you didn't think that was weird
I thought he was trick-or-treating in
December maybe he was from a different
time zone no he never came back that's
probably because it was too busy turning
me into Denny's Grand Slam at least you
got served I just don't get it why now
don't you see
Danny's gone you were out there trying
to separate us
hey Donnie how come you want to make
movies if all you do is criticize him
well it might have been him Hollywood's
got it coming so this is independent
filmmakers crusade against Hollywood
have you ever have you ever tried going
out there I don't need to I I know
there's bad stuff out there well like an
axe is bad stuff I mean everything I've
heard about how he was never been good
you know they they make these movies are
supposed to make it feel really good you
know and and and make you escape the
pains of your real life but when you go
to Hollywood the pain is there it's
always there and how he would never let
you forget that have you even like lived
in California like any other to live in
California I've heard enough about it
you know and what have you what any like
murder mysteries or a script of what
your mother told you to stay away from
Hollywood was that it you do you never
said was she staged your screen like
what would I what would I ain't know her
from there think I'm gonna be sick
that's six of those yes
[Music]
doing this the Irish week
Oh firearms and alcohol there's a safe
combination would you rather be sober
when the IKEA bunch comes and makes the
rooty tooty fresh and fruity breakfast
platter out your ass me I'm gonna be
ready for him I don't worry - come on
I'm a security guard and Quinn's
military background is one fucking
defeated what could go wrong I guess
you're right hey this stuff's pretty
good mate a great after-school snack
did you guys hear that
Rebecca
vos pearl what the hell's going on in
there what you might call shore leave
those to sway players and a sexy Pikachu
yeah hell did you get them
here's a tip there on accent welcome to
be my pokeball
[Music]
a Shirley Temple
by this whole time thing see ya Amiga
record time ducrai
nice to meet you
[Applause]
Doni hey y'all said to hang out today
not exactly daddy whose guy we're
talking about animating the hangouts how
about holding my oh my god dude looks
like you guys had a lot of fun drinking
last night boundary
I'm really confused how does this work
they're in costume they're in character
they're from Oona gage and we talked to
them if you want someone will come by
with a diet coke or something sugary on
plates they don't have to be maids
they're in costume what do they serve do
you have anything on ten I mean you
could talk about new friends that you
made this weekend I mean you you talk
about how much of a great metal gear
awesome time you had last night would
you do the tall best friend sorry I
don't even drink I'm just naturally five
years old
wasn't there anyone else there to shower
you
torment ended at 17 my watch is racing
the denim I want to be the very best
like no one ever was
[Applause]
[Music]
I will travel across the land
gotcha come on
[Applause]
[Music]
so what do you think worst meal ever
I'll say I can make if a actually has
amendment I mean you're all set to go
you got your ticket yeah yeah yeah leave
today yeah what you sitting have fun man
you have a safe flight was yeah yeah
yeah it was definitely an experience
yeah
[Music]
fiction the item in the suitcase
israelian gold an engine that can run on
water and an inception where you don't
know if everything was actually a dream
or not it actually was a dream in fact
all of it was just saw was the genic
made to see brought on by Jack before he
died in Titanic at the end of 2001 a
Space Odyssey pretty much just becomes
the next evolution of mankind except he
sees the earth as one giant ii desuka
and that's really gonna suck for us no
pun intended and a loss in translation
when Bill Murray is whispering to
Scarlett Johansson he's really just
telling it where to find a good sushi
place there that's farro but anything's
you don't have to worry about anymore
next April
I will have a great place
[Music]
first I have tectonic girl
oh boy I tell you that was a trip that
was definitely a trip I mean it's one of
those trips where yeah some bad stuff
happened but you feel a little wiser no
you feel a wise the whose idea was it to
you know actually send a car to pick me
up and Mail's real nice holding to sign
up and everything but who came up with
that was that Rebecca or Tacoma uh it
was that their idea to the hold the gun
in my face and hi
[Music]